in other news mary trump
niece of former president donald trump
came out with a phenomenal article in
the new republic recently
where she basically
well she psychoanalyzed a lot
of her uncle's administration but
there's one part that i want to hit on
more than others
and that is the part where she talks
about the big lie right the big lie that
the election was stolen which as she
points out donald trump began telling
that lie on november 7th which was the
day that the 2020 election was
officially called for joe biden
and on that very day he started the big
lie
and of course he had all the horrible
people whispering in his ear that oh
yeah you got to do this giuliani was
there
mark meadows was there
all these individuals
even some private lawyers telling him
you've got to challenge us you got to
say it was fake
and mary trump says that the reason her
uncle did this
is because he was absolutely
humiliated
humiliated
by the fact
that he lost the presidential election
to joe
biden
all this was
was his hubris
not allowing him to accept the fact that
he lost to somebody like joe biden
and so he had to as a defense mechanism
for himself
create this alternative timeline this
alternative reality
where in his head
he actually won the election because of
all the fraud
so we had the election challenges we've
had the recounts
we've had to go through and recertify
we've had the signature match we now
have the ballot audits and all of it
she points out is this defense mechanism
to protect his bruised ego
the humiliation that he still feels to
this day
losing that election
but the problem is his delusion
his defense mechanism is not just
limited to him now
it is
in psychological terms a shared
psychosis now
right it has seemingly infected millions
of others
who have now been sucked into the
delusion
to believe that the 2020 election was
stolen i mean how many polls have we
seen just over the last two months
showing a majority of republicans now
think the election
was stolen
that's a terrifying thought i haven't
seen any polls in the last couple weeks
so maybe that number's changed maybe
it's gone back down and you don't have a
majority of republicans thinking that
anymore but the fact that we ever did
that we ever even hit 60 percent of
republicans saying this is terrifying
because there was never any fraud
in fact the few cases of fraud that we
found the individual cases all appear to
be trump supporters
that's what we're living with but they
still can't accept it because he won't
accept it and he'll never accept it
till the day he dies donald trump every
time he gets in front of a camera or he
gets a microphone is going to remind us
that he thinks the 2020 election was
stolen
he has done that this year every time he
gets on stage every time he has an
audience he says the same thing
even though the ballot audits have
produced no fraud even though the
recounts have produced no fraud even
though the lawsuits have produced no
fraud
even though the cyber symposium produced
no hacking evidence at all no fraud
he'll never stop
and marry trump's explanation of this
really lays it all bare
he won't stop because he can't stop
because his narcissism simply won't let
him
i am farron cousins in for david pakman
we'll be right back with more of the
david pakman show
do not forget that one of the best ways
to support the david pakman show is by
supporting our awesome sponsors and
today one of those sponsors is sheath
underwear
the weather is warming up it's hotter
it's stickier out there and
unfortunately for many of us that comes
with a lot of sticking and rubbing and
chafing with traditional underwear
that is what sheath underwear has solved
sheath has developed unique boxer briefs
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front preventing skin on skin
contact that means everything stays
separate dry cool and comfortable with
sheath underwear there is no more
sweating no more chafing no more
readjusting it's great sheath underwear
is giving the david pakman show audience
20 off
when you go to sheath underwear dot com
slash pacman and use the promo code
pacman give sheath underwear a try
my experience has been great i believe
yours will be as well you can find the
link underneath this video and do not
forget to use that promo code pacman for
20 off